china has again said it will quote
reunite taiwan with the mainland as
tensions ramp up further between beijing
and the self-governing island chinese
president xi jinping told a communist
party gathering that such a move would
happen peacefully and said china could
never tolerate any form of separatism
taiwan has responded by saying it's a
sovereign nation and that its people
will decide their future taipei has been
bristling over china's recent military
incursions from taipei i'm joined by dw
correspondent joyce lee joyce chinese
president xi jinping saying that uh
reunification should be by peaceful
means but what is he signaling with that
language is it in fact a kind of threat
well yes it is a remark made just before
the national day of taiwan
but it's worth noting that mr c
used a softer tone
compared to the speech he gave in july
in which he vowed to uh smash any
attempts to of
a formal
taiwan independence and two years ago he
directly threatened to take taiwan by
force
nonetheless xi jinping said in
the latest speech that
the reunification
will happen and can happen
so
the speech is poorly received by taiwan
the presidential office said that the
future of taiwan lay in the hands of
taiwanese people
so a softening of the rhetoric there
perhaps but escalations uh tensions have
been escalating rather how are people
there on the street reacting to this
escalation
well this is not the first time beijing
has said something like that and people
in taiwan are very used to
the threats and harassment from beijing
um it's worth noting that uh xi jinping
said that uh he wants to see a peaceful
reunification um
you know occur under the one country two
systems uh framework which uh was also
employed in hong kong and uh taiwanese
people have been witnessing what's been
happening in hong kong for the past few
years the suppression of political
freedom and freedom of speech so
according to
a latest opinion poll
nearly 90 percent of taiwanese people
reject the one country to system
framework it is a policy that is no
longer convincing to the taiwanese
people
why is taiwan so important for china why
is this reunification threats coming now
well the chinese communist party has
never reached taiwan but china sees
taiwan as a breakaway uh province so um
former colonies like hong kong and macau
uh were handed back to china in the 90s
and uh it's just
you know
beijing sees taiwan as you know um the
next uh province that has to be
handed back to the motherland so if xi
jinping succeeds in doing so he would
become a national hero in rejuvenating
the chinese nation and uh we should note
that
he is still to complete his second term
next year and uh he's expected to stay
in power for life um
so he needs um something to
you know
build the legitimacy especially uh amid
a series of crisis in china uh say the
power crisis as well as the economic
slowdown
all right joyce thank you dw's joyce lee
reporting from taipei